le goncourt des lycéens à 2012 c'est
donc parti la liste des ouvrages en
compétition vient d'être dévoilée on
regarde d'abord ce sujet de la rédaction
et puis on en parle avec nos invités sur
ce plateau pour le 7-8 toujours en
direct jusqu'à 19 heures
onze livres à lire en seulement deux
mois c'est le défi que va relever cette
classe de première l du lycée jean vilar
à plaisir choisi pour attribuer le
goncourt des lycéens les ouvrages sont
les mêmes que ceux sélectionnés pour le
prix goncourt
tous les élèves de la classe lisent les
livres ou du moins un maximum de livres
ensuite nous faisons un débat à huis
clos et nous désignons à tiercé et un
délégué et ce délégué de classe ira pour
les élections régionales au mois de
novembre à paris et là il y aura à
nouveau un tiercé est un saint dernier
tour pour une élection nationale
seuls deux lycées de la région
ile-de-france ont été sélectionnés au
total une cinquantaine y participent à
travers la france une façon de mieux
appréhender le bac français à la fin de
l'année et de s'ouvrir à la lecture
c'est une formidable expérience de
lecture donc nous avons des élèves et
air air doux qui sont des vecteurs mais
bon tous ne sont pas forcément des
grands lecteurs donc là c'est vraiment
l'occasion pour les élèves de découvrir
la littérature contemporaine puisque ce
ne sont que des titres très récent et de
stimuler un goût pour la lecture de
déclencher un appétit de lecture ouais
une bonne expérience et on va au refuge
où culture comment c'est difficile parce
qu'il y en a beaucoup y en a onze donc
il faut faire vite quoi j'aime bien lire
mais je suis pas forcément une grande
vitesse de classiques plutôt de ceux
plus moderne type fantastique romance
le prix goncourt des lycéens a été créée
en 1988 par la fnac qui fournit une
dizaine d'exemplaires de chaque livre
aux classes concernées il sera remis
début novembre quelques jours après son
aîné
le goncourt des lycéens permet à peu
près à 2000 élèves en france 2 lire et
d'étudier est la sélection de romans de
la liste du goncourt le fameux concours
national une cinquantaine de classes de
lycées âgés de15 de lycéens âgés de 15 à
18 ans issus de seconde première
terminale bts généralistes scientifiques
ou techniques sont concernés et
notamment ceux du lycée jean vilar de
plaisir nous les recevons ce soir sur le
plateau bonsoir aller à beaucaire est
élève en première es littéraire dans ce
lycée at-on dit également et puis à
mélissa et à votre enseignante qui vous
accompagne et nathalie mais bon soir
professeur de lettres du lycée jean
vilar à plaisir et c'est vous qui avait
décidé d'inscrire votre place vous avez
postulé auprès de l'académie du goncourt
des lycéens pourquoi tout simplement
déjà expliquez-nous ce choix parce que
c'est du travail ensuite pour vous et
puis pour les élèves oui moi c'est du
travail mais si c'est aussi beaucoup de
plaisir donc j'ai déposé des lettres de
candidature on a eu la chance d'être
retenue et si jean vilar a eu la chance
d'être retenue est bon alors pourquoi
parce que c'est une formidable aventure
avec une première littéraire même si
certains professeurs
accomplissent cette aventure avec
d'autres casques des classes littéraires
mais aussi voilà voilà champion mais je
trouvais que c'était une très bonne
façon de valoriser notre filière l2
d'inciter les élèves à lire d'aiguiser
leur regard de lecteurs voilà de leur
apprendre à débattre bon il ya tout un
tas de compétences qu'on peut acquérir à
travers ce goncourt des lycéens donc
vous avez postulé pour participer il ya
que deux établissements d'île de france
dont le lycée villar à plaisir forcément
pour vous c'était une bonne surprise
d'avoir été retenus sélectionnés par le
goncourt des lycéens pour les élèves ça
a été une bonne surprise aussi parce que
la semaine dernière vous êtes rentré en
cours et vous avez découvert qu'il
allait falloir lire 11 livres d'ici le
mois de novembre on a parlé un petit peu
de l'organisation de ce concours dans un
instant c'était une bonne surprise ou
pas quand vous êtes arrivé c'était
vraiment une grande surprise un honneur
vraiment parce que le vrai concours
c'est vraiment pas rien j'avais moi je
connaissais pas vraiment c'est plutôt
j'ai ouvert un bouquin je devais être en
quatrième et j'ai lu le rapport de
brodeck ont dû m'intéressait vraiment ça
c'était par hasard et du coup le fait
que je me retrouve là cette année dans
une classe justement qui a été
sélectionné pour ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très intéressant parce
que vos camarades partage votre aviez
vous allez forcément nous dire oui on
sait le début de l'année on va pas se
fâcher avec l'enseignante
vous connaissiez déjà le goncourt des
lycéens ou pas et ça fait ça fait partie
de vos lectures justement l'édition de
l'an dernier par exemple le goncourt
2011 vous l'avez vous l'aviez lui non
mais c'est plus même mère qui l'a vu
parce que c'est un peu complexe d'accord
lorsque vous m'en sers de la cour des
lycéens ça représente quoi pour vous bah
c'est une alternative aux français
puisque jusqu'à présent d'un programme
qui est plus classique donc là on peut
vraiment de faire de la littérature
contemporaine donc c'est vrai que ça
donne un autre regard parce que quand on
voit que du balzac flaubert etc c'est
bien mais ça plaît pas à tout le monde
et là d'avoir une grosse liste quand
même été sélectionné par l'académie ça
permet d'avoir des livres de qualité et
qui sont dans une langue qui nous est
plus proche donc c'est vraiment grave un
mot tout de même sur cette liste
justement on ce titre enfin 12 en fait
pour le goncourt mais il y en a un
d'entre eux qui n'a pas été laissé les
cas n'a pas été retenu pour le goncourt
des lycéens c'est bien c'est mathias
enard parce qu'il a déjà eu le goncourt
des lycéens il ya deux ans donc on ne
peut pas avoir deux années de suite le
enfin deux fois de suite où il parle pas
de suite mais deux fois le goncourt ou
le goncourt des lycéens donc deux
ouvrages pour le goncourt est classique
on va dire aux issues de ces douze
tomber on sait que vous avez cités on
peut citer quelques uns de ses titres
serge bramly orchidées fixe patrick
deville peste et choléra ce genre
d'ouvragé ça fait partie de choses que
vous auriez proposé peut-être à la
lecture spontanément déjà tous les ans
avec mes classes de première ou de
seconde
j'étudie vraiment de la littérature
contemporaine est de plus en plus dans
les programmes on m a confronté les
romans du xixème par exemple et puis les
romans d'aujourd'hui y suivre un petit
peu l'évolution du personnage de roman
c'est très très intéressant évidemment
et cette sélection d'ouvragés vous en
pensez quoi alors bonne sélection
écoutez si vous n'avez pas le droit de
prononcer un an je vais me retrouver un
billet en fait je ne connais pas les
oeuvres donc je vais découvrir et c'est
ça l'intérêt en même temps que les
élèves ils auront même un petit avantage
sur sur sur moi c'est qu'ils pourront
argumente exprimer leur opinion et nous
les professeurs nous sommes tenus alain
plus stricte neutralité pour ne pas les
influencer c'est vraiment leur prix à
eux est ce que vous avez commencé à les
lire c'est aux ouvrages ou pas oui alors
vous avez commencé par lire quoi parce
que le choix est libre les ouvrages
tourner dans la classe et vous les
partagez donc vous allez commencer par
quoi qui se lancent un fonds grec ouais
le terroriste noir et pour vous dire
qu'il est fixé à continuer le tour de
table vous en avez pensé quoi vous en
êtes où dans la lecture je me suis
seulement à la motié donc et c'est assez
intéressant c'est je pensais que ce
serait plus compliqué à lire et
finalement c'est c'est facile de lecture
et puis bah on se fonde dans le milieu
en voyage à travers ce que l'écrivain
nous fait passer ce serait intéressant
et c'est ce que vous attendez justement
des livres que vous lisez par exemple
pour vous tombiez vous attendez quoi
d'un bon roman d'un bon livre
un roman qui nous permettent de
ressentir un peu les personnages pas
forcément qu'ils nous donnent des plages
des descriptions mais qu'on arrive
justement à s'identifier à eux on
s'imagine et qu'on puisse rentrer
vraiment dans un univers différent pour
moi c'est un roman qui réussissent quand
vraiment bas on aime à lire parce qu'on
a envie de savoir ce qui se passe parce
que ça nous tient vraiment à coeur que
c'est presque viscéral quoi c'est celui
que vous avez commencé donc c'était
lequel vous nous avez dit le terroriste
et noir pour l'histoire un peu c'est
donc sur les tirailleurs sénégalais
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale et
d'information j'ai commencé il y perd un
peu je suis un peu perdu dans ce que
c'est avec beaucoup de personnages et
une promène beaucoup l'auteur donc pour
le moment j'ai pas pris de repères donc
j'ai un peu du mal et en ce qui vous
concerne alors sur le livre que vous
avez commencé à orchidées fixe alors je
pense qu'il faut vraiment qu'il ya un
rapport en fait entre le langage de
l'auteur et l'émotion du lecteur en fait
et
qu'on puisse vraiment se plonger dans la
lecture tout ça donc ce qui est fort qui
les fixe au halal il est vraiment pas
mal parce qu'en fait ça parle d'un
un d'un artiste et de sa biographie donc
c'est assez intéressant c'est assez dans
une période un peu critique puisque
c'est la guerre la première guerre
mondiale donc moi je suis à la moitié
aussi donc j'attends encore vous en
pensez quoi de ces analyses de ses
élèves y sont déjà oui oui comme les
allemands viennent de débuter leur vie
de la bonne maturité de lecture et puis
comme on fera forcément un bilan sur ce
qui peut faire un bon roman il n'y a pas
une réponse évidemment il ya de
multiples réponses et il y en a déjà eu
quelques unes alors vous parlais
justement du plaisir un plaisir par
forces avenir du travail et plaisir
lorsque vous lisez ces ouvrages lorsque
vous allez devoir lire ses différents
ouvrages pour vous l'appréhendez comment
là vous avez commencé ça comme étant une
contrainte un travail supplémentaire
parce qu'elle programme de l'année à
faire aussi bien mais c'est toujours
dans le plaisir je veux dire la lecture
c'est enrichissant c'est un temps à
prendre vraiment pour pour soi pour les
autres français c'est important en
première littéraire ça simplifie aussi
le travail un bon pense aussi à vos
collègues qui ne sont pas avec des 1re
littéraire pour participer c'est
peut-être un peu plus dur là vous avez
déjà pas ce travail à faire de leur
faire aimer les livres il sème déjà
c'est sûrement un public beaucoup plus
facile que d'autres comment ça va se
passer le travail maintenant tout au
long de l'année ils ont commencé les
ouvrages et il va falloir très rapide
mots à sortir les premières analyses les
tracteurs demandions ce sera pas tout au
long de l'année ce sera durant huit dix
semaines et donc lecture on va faire des
débats hebdomadaire
voilà donc pour confronter les points de
vue il ya un journal de bord qui est
tenu aussi par la classe qui donc il ya
deux des quatre élèves qui s'occupe du
journal de bord qui sont ici ce soir et
donc ils vont collecter les impressions
des élèves les articles les voilà les
billets d'humeur bon donc nous allons
débattre nous allons apprendre à
argumenter il s'agira également de de
rédiger des critiques alors de façon
peut-être un peu plus exigeante qu'à
l'oral voilà et puis ensuite
entre le 12 et le gain de 15 novembre
auront lieu les trois débats à huis clos
1 dans la classe 1 au niveau régional et
puis enfin le dernier débat à rennes à
la brasserie la chope selon la tradition
et tous ces débats donc tous les
étudiants tous les lycéens ils vont y
participer le tout les touts les la
classe pour le premier débat toute la
classe participe élit un représentant
qui se rendent et lendemain donc ce sera
le mardi 13 novembre ou à paris je pense
ce sera présent règlement dans une fnac
qui rencontrera les représentants des
autres le lycée et ils feront une
nouvelle élection et nous d'un tiercé
qui doit rester secret et une nouvelle
élection de représentants pour la
dernière élection de rennes il y en a
certains d'entre vous parmi vous 3 qu'il
souhaiterait justement aller jusqu'à
rennes nous voit juste
la concurrence va être dure falloir
convaincre avec camarades comment ça se
passe d'ailleurs pour les départager
s'ils veulent conserver en fait d'abord
la première condition c'est d'avoir lu
absolument tous les livres et puis
d'avoir une bonne capacité
d'argumentation parce qu'il faut savoir
prendre la parole défendre son point de
vue écouter les autres tenir compte de
ce qu'ils disent aussi et voilà donc ça
demande quand même beaucoup de qualités
mais je ne doute pas qu il les possède
et à mon avis il ya encore d'autres
rivaux au sein de la classe faut lancer
la compétition entre vous élève vous
avez déjà participé à l'opération
c'était en 2002 et en général comment ça
se passe ya des débats passionnés dans
la classe où il y avait eu des débats
passionnés mais quand même il ya des
débats passionnés sur certains livres
mais il se trouve que cette année là
toute la classe s'est retrouvé autour de
laurent gaudé la mort du roi tsongor
puisque c'était l'année 2002 et je pense
qu'à l'élection lors du débat à rennes
il n'y a pas eu tant de débats il n'y
avait pas eu tant de discussion que cela
et tous les avis ont quand même plus ou
moins assez vite converger pour laurent
gaudé ya tout ça dépend des années il
vous faudra lire donc les onze ouvrages
ont été sélectionnés vous allez tous les
lire forcément il y en a certains que
vous n'avez pas envie de lire vous avez
des a priori sur certains
voient le policier en fait me fait un
peu c'est pourquoi j'ai pas très
policiers n'ont pas ce genre littéraire
qui bouge qui vous plaît pas trop non
pas vraiment je suis plutôt romantique
tout sa correspondance après classique
aussi
écouter bonne lecture à tous trois et
puis à tous vos camarades de classe ils
sont combien dans la classe en tout cas
partie des 32 falloir discount à tous
les livres merci d'être venus sur
plateau nous paraît donc de cette
opération vous suis vraiment au long de
l'année voir un petit peu comment ça ça
a évolué pourquoi pas venir vous voir
directement dans la classe voir s'il ya
des débats passionnés justement entre
les élèves la suite du 7 8 sur tv fils
en direct jusqu'à 19 heures avec une
page environnement maxime le men va
venir nous présenter nouvelle résidence
universitaire entièrement en bois c'est
à versailles je recevrai aussi
jean-françois vigouroux le président de
la chambre syndicale des buralistes des
yvelines là des buralistes toujours en
colère contre les projets de plans anti
tabac du gouvernement également de
bruxelles en attendant on fait une pause
plutôt romantique avec un couple le
couple d'espère qui vient de célébrer
ses noces de platine 70 ans de mariage à
catherine plateau et guillaume quand
on connaît géant d'espère le poète
yvelinois on découvre l'homme amoureux
qui vient de célébrer en mairie de
versailles ces noces de platine 70 ans
de mariage avec son épouse jeanine pour
coup de chance alors d'avoir pu vivre
cependant on a fait son amant comme tout
le monde on a ainsi dû vivre le mieux
possible nos maisons nos cinq sens le
mieux possible
le couple d'espère est à la tête d'une
tribu comme il aime la décrire cinq
enfants 14 petits enfants et 11 arrière
petits enfants mais se recueillir
ensemble d'être autonomes ils sont
toujours devant semble donc ça c'est
merveilleux et de les voir aussi bien
sans toi je vois pas pas encore prendre
la main de maman et dire regardez comme
elle est belle c'est merveilleux
effectivement en terminant tout long
terme d'attachement et d'amour mutuel
c'est clairement un modèle après
effectivement là le modèle des cinq
enfants est peut-être passé du transport
sera derrière mais en tout cas en termes
d'affection c'est clairement un voyage
jeanine et jehan se sont rencontrés à
versailles le 17 mai 40 dans un centre
de réfugiés deux ans plus tard et se
sont mariés ici même dans cette salle de
la mairie de versailles
bobigny
résumé très fort
je te parlais des stars là tous les deux
ensemble c'est une joie savait et
l'amour est toujours là et la mort est
toujours là et ça brive peut le dire et
lui je crois qu'ils étaient une des roxy
non vivre au jour le jour le mieux
possible
aimer les gens autour de nous
c'est simple
c'est donc en toute simplicité entourés
de leur tribu mais non sans émotion que
le couple d'esperce et redit oui et pour
l'occasion jurant l'éternel amoureux
offert une bague à jeanine l'amour qui
perdure serait écrit tous les jours